This housing problem is multiplying throughout Spain and today we
are seeing how 13 provincial capitals are in a very similar situation,
while others are being emptied.
Of course,
other provinces,
because among other things they choose a place like Madrid to come and live,
fleeing from their liberticidal policies that
when they have been applied in a radical way,
as they did in the city council of Madrid or
as they have done in the city council of Malaga,
They have shot up prices and because citizens can not afford rent or purchase.
You have been impeded and listen,
you have been educated and listen.
I am speaking now.
Thank you in question time and listen to the political discrepancy,
that's why we are in 1 parliament and I'll tell you in Spanish,
listen to me.
They have prevented by making a pact with Bildu,
with Bildu and its sectarian laws.
They have prevented urban development,
they have already multiplied the price of housing,
they have read the reports and stop
sectarianism and also with their funny policies,
homeowners feel insecure and right now they are just taking steps
forward by putting many clauses and difficulties in turn to the tenant,
therefore the liberticidal,
sectarian and dogmatic policies that defends the ultra-left,
triggers the prices,
sinks the supply and is the incentive and the biggest problem we have,
so we are implementing rental plans as 1 purchase does with
the young solution plan with 1,200 homes in 6 municipalities.
The plan lives that it is building,
building 4 900.
Do not attack bricks or companies,
please.
We are working.
Do not disturb.
And also the plan of my first home.
We are taking steps to expand the offer.
And we are also helping young people with flat
fares on the best public transportation in the country,
with record scholarships,
with help to start businesses.
Because young people are also
entrepreneurs and don't want to be rich as you say.
They want to be free,
to own property and create jobs,
programs for training and employment,
plans to help the birth rate,
to help farmers,
the winners.
Find out a little more and be proud of
what the Madrilenians are achieving in Madrid.
Please.
Thank you